peace be with you welcome to the Dean
shell subscribe if you have not
subscribed already I'm excited and I'm
sure you'll be too because I have an
exciting guest here you know we made the
Filipino connection you know Manny
Pacquiao from the Filipinos that's right
but this guy this brother he actually
accepted this Deen his way of life long
time ago and he's got an X credible
story went from hanging out at the White
House now he's hanging out here at the D
show don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with this fascinating story this is
peace be with you
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam ah how
are you my brother he loud feeling good
now you heard me mention I was time up
Manny Pacquiao with the Filipino
connection have you ever met Manny I
have not but he's from the same place
where you originally from your parents
are flowers are from yes yeah Filipino I
know it so we got how's the community
out there community predominately is in
the south and this is just a long story
of oppression mm-hmm by the government
it's a predominantly Christian country
predominantly Catholic and the Muslims
in the South arrived in Mindanao and are
actually called Morrow's which has a
connection to the Moors of North Africa
so yeah it's a there's about five
percent it was much more before but
because of politics oppression and other
things it's been very challenging for
the Filipino Muslims in the south but
there is a big resurgence and a big
movement where a lot of people are
converting to Islam there in the
Philippines so yeah
it's the natural way I called you to do
something that's in your nature to
worship the Creator not the creation
it's simple to understand its logical
make sense and that's or really
captivated you that you actually went
you went and studied in the desert yeah
you were out there huh for several years
wanting to get close to the Creator you
you accepted Islam I meant one Filipino
Muslim because I didn't know I mean I
the it's very scarce to to find a
Filipino Muslim what's the project
primarily it's a predominant Christian
Christian country and Catholic so you
had some influence also over Moses Moosa
Musa Musa Hamato over to be an imam also
in what city South Africa he's now
currently in Cleveland hum did it nice
so what happened how did all this start
so yeah it's interesting we you bring up
Musa and like there's other people that
are tied to Southern California
community or to the Filipino community
and a lot of those converts actually you
know and a lug Heidi allows the one that
guides and allows the one that makes
people become Muslim not the people
right and yeah with Musa Ron all the
other people that we've mentioned the
fact everyone pretty much converted
after me so when I converted I got
kicked out of my home went through some
trials and tribulations and then
masha'Allah like everyone around me
converted now you might get we got you
know some not yet Muslims Filipino
they're gonna be excited you know oh
that's our countrymen to tune in yeah
I'm said some Arabic words and actually
speak Arabic also I speak fluent coming
LA so you didn't you didn't become an
Arab did you know but someone heard
Muslim yeah they heard Allah can you
tell us for the Filipinos oh and all
that yeah he went somewhere else yes
Islam is you know it stands for peace
the religion of peace and Muslim is
someone who practices the religion of
Islam so it's like you know your Judaism
if you practice Judaism you're Jewish if
you practice religion of Islam you're a
Muslim Allah is the same as el dios it's
the definitive article Allah is like el
dios the God so allah el dios the god
it's all the same so we all believe in
the one true creator piece of people get
amazing I tell people that look mo Moses
Abraham Jesus they're all Muslim they
submitted to the will of God does it
create and that's what we're doing
that's it yeah so tell us now what took
you on his journey you came from a
hip-hop culture music dis music yeah
yeah you know yeah and your whole life
was probably around like most people
just materialism and you forgot about
the soul the heart mind it was just you
know fulfilling what people want to
fulfill you know those temporary
enjoyments yeah what had you come to a
point where you got real serious in life
um there were some things that occurred
you know with
very troubling times in my life before
Islam whether it was through particular
deaths through violence it was me always
having a contemplative soul in mind of
being influenced by hip-hop that was
conscious that made you think about
politics the effects of you know
politics on Finance people's living
standards the disparity of poverty and
wealth and these kinds of things made me
think about my own soul and about my
place in this world so yes I lived a
very worldly life a very colorful
experience before Islam but always in
the back of my mind I always used to
always think like I was created for
something grander than there's something
bigger than this on your way here you
mentioned that she says something to the
to the the cat the uber driver yeah what
did you tell him I told him that what
Islam is done for you yeah it was funny
because it's affected my whole entire
life like it the businesses I run of
emotionally financially spiritually
mentally and I didn't know everything
that I've done in my life would lead to
this and right before I was gonna say
anything he goes it was the best
decision you've made in your life and I
said it actually was you know tell us
some some people looking out there they
say look why didn't you just stick with
worshipping Jesus as the Son of God
dying for your sin staying a Christian
what happened here for me it was God put
me in a position where I was able I
don't know why but I was able to take a
step back from religion and just look at
him also I studied you know Jude you
know Judaism Islam Christianity Buddhism
Confucianism Sikh you know Jainism and
all of the different faiths and it was
to put it succinctly Islam was the most
intellectually like satiated me and it
the idea of one true creator was
something that I could easily swallow
most people have a hard time with
creation worship worshipping a man you
know most people don't know that we love
Jesus
but as a mighty messenger not as a god
or literal son of God but people love
this direct connection I'm going through
intermediary yeah so this also and it
connects with the fitrah yeah what they
Nate nature the Nate nature and that was
probably Eddie was that the radical
departure and understanding of one true
God that Islam really really drills down
was probably the most appealing thing to
me which is that Wow
you know that's what I always believed
before in my life always in my life that
there was one true creator and Islam's
take on it was just so that was just it
made most sense to me
it made the most sense to me and it was
very easy to convert a lot more to talk
about we mentioned the White House
you've been all over the world traveling
entrepreneur here on the Dean show or my
special guest don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
oh can you put your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things gotta happen to
you in your life and then what have you
got at the end of the day is an empty
dream that has no real foundation we are
gonna dine and we're gonna meet our Lord
and He is gonna judge us salam says love
all mankind that's why we're sharing
this message because we want the best
for you and we want the best for all
mankind please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now I mentioned the
white house did you get a chance to give
President Obama some dollar
actually it was funny we started talking
but if I could take a step back I'm sure
when when people talk about this you
know people going to the White House
people meeting the president and all the
different hadith and things from our
tradition that talk about these kinds of
interactions for me what was the
compelling force was my mother my mother
when I became Muslim I got kicked out of
my home because they despised my
religion and they hated it and I did
some things to actually make them really
not like my faith and Hum Dil I went
overseas I studied for four years came
back home and when I was overseas it was
my mother who was the first one to
convert to us
and after that my father became Muslim
you have to remember these are people
who kicked me out of my home because
they did not they hated my religion that
my sister became my family became my
best friend became Muslim his family
became Muslim our friends became Muslim
their friends became Muslim people with
me become Muslim their families become
Muslim so when I got the invitation it
was my mother who got it and she was
besides herself she was elated and she
was just couldn't believe that it was
her son that did this and she remembers
the you know the day before I was
leaving to go to Africa to study and you
know when I converted and all these
memories were playing into her mind and
when she was just like my baby's going
to the White House he's gonna he's gonna
be having to it for me was something
that to honor my mother because of
everything she's did took for her to
convert at such an old age to have the
resiliency to practice to have it affect
my father and the rest of my family it
was my mother who like was the reason
why I went and I went from our mother I
went for my father and I went for
everything I stood for because it was
just for my mom and dad it was just like
one of the I'd never seen them so proud
and I forgotten degrees and I've done
things with my life but it was just like
wow this is our son and you did
something that people just don't do so
yeah I went there and as actually I mean
I have to admit I mean President Obama's
a really nice guy as a man as a human
being you know aside from everything
else he's just a good man and we were
able to talk about some funny things and
I'll just leave it at that but it was it
was pretty interesting now all these
people except in Islam God Almighty
Allah is the one who guys but you were
able to have a great influence they
invite you down the White House to say
slow down to Dawa no no no actually from
what I've been told and you know it the
fact that in our faith sometimes it's or
even in the in the religion that the the
pursuit of acquiring you know
or good life in the world is exclusive
or to the detriment of your afterlife or
if you chase after your afterlife your
your dunya you know your worldly life is
gonna be affected and I guess people I
don't know God knows best they see
someone that has been able to I guess go
down both paths and be balanced and not
compromise one for the other I don't
know God knows best of why people you
know think of me that way
but yeah it's affected the way I do
business
Islam permeates a lot of it right in a
lot of the foundations and the
principles and the ethics that I
practice is because of it
now why was your family so upset in the
beginning so angered that they kicked
you out when obviously if people look
and they see okay is a Muslim he's doing
what Jesus did Moses Abraham he just
submitted to God he just wants to be a
better human being Islam helps you if
you practice it right to develop
yourself to be the best human being much
better to your neighbor to your parents
in business and everything yeah so you
know why did they have such a difficulty
accepting this in the beginning a lot of
it has to do with media um my parents
are just you know they're the common
American where they watch TV after they
get home from work and whatever the
media tells them whatever the news is
they'll be like son we were watching the
news and in Nigeria this is what's
happening and why is this occurring in
Saudi Arabia and why did they do that to
women in Pakistan and why is this going
on in Egypt
you know why is your religion so violent
and I can't blame them right as people
who are concerned with paying their
bills keeping the lights on raising good
children they don't have the time to dig
deep to do research to investigate
people do right people do have the time
if a law was to take everything from
your life you still have time but I
understand from the human perspective
that people have some difficulties
getting to those because they're so
concerned with the affairs that bog them
down daily so it was the media that did
that for my mother and father so when
they would see me going
actually deeper into my newfound faith
they found it very troublesome and also
the way I was I was super super hard on
them
and I was just telling them all kinds of
things that were just very you know like
get rid of all the alcohol in this house
and did theirs and they're like who are
you like we used you know we raised you
so who are you to tell us what to do so
I had a hand in that too but a lot of it
had to do with the media right now
people are seeing a statistic and
actually this is just really way out
there when the media purposely they go
ahead and twist the truth and blow
things out of proportion people have
more of a chance of being killed by a
shark by dog bite their furniture then
actually a Muslim terrorist I mean we
know this is the antithesis to Islam you
know it's but imagine it would give
these examples you know if the media
just played to all the violence that's
happening we love our country here but
obviously there's a lot of things that
are going on well in America and if
people outside of the world were just
you know focusing on all the violence
here it'd be a scary thing right people
like why are you going over there that's
a war zone yeah you know for me I've
come to realize Eddie through my travels
and experiences in life that every human
being has an agenda every group has an
agenda every company has an agenda so
for the powers that be I mean I have an
agenda right like I want to please my
parents I want to be the best son I can
be the best neighbor I can be and I'm
gonna do what I need to do to achieve
that so for companies they have
different goals right
they have different people that they
need to please you and your life you
have different people you need to please
so you do things and when you do things
it may not be liked by other people
right so what I've come to realize is
that I'm here to do my job
sincerely for the sake of my creator and
to the beat to be the best at it and
only God can stop me God willing you
know like I'm gonna try to be the best
that I can be tell us what was a turning
bore how far down later after you
accepted submission
one of the crater Islam did your parents
do they end up accepting my mom
converted probably I want to say two
three two or three years after me not
too long later nah not too long that's
such a blessing yes what was it for them
also they started they saw you the
proving your character because I would
say that was probably like for a lot of
people it you know all praises due to
God like as a as a as a man as I've just
been blessed I when I really want
something and Allah God knows like in my
heart what I want to do and it's
sincerely to be the best that I can be
to be the best person I can be I can
make that change and I think when people
saw me change from how I was to how I
you know was how I became as a Muslim
people really deeply affected by that my
mother my father my friends people in my
community people from my neighborhood
people were just like wow he really
changed he'll change after six months
than six months became a gear and here
became two years so for a lot of the
people that started questioning it was
what made him change and what is this
piece that he currently has now this
stability and this outlook of life and
this positivity like how do I get that
and I think that was you know God knows
best people saw their change in me and
wanted it for themselves I was like a
miracle
hey there's even people now your parents
could sleep at night it's probably from
all the ruckus before you were started
okay we're gonna take you speak Filipino
no I don't I understand Tagalog which is
the national language but no how to say
hi bye we'll be right back and uh
actually I don't
okay we'll be right back here in addy
show with more don't go anywhere
the question is about whether Muslims
are not good citizens the Constitution
defines what a good citizen is and the
preamble it says we the people of the
United States and I will form a more
perfect union establish justice ensure
domestic tranquility Sunni Muslim they
can say that is a good
and most Muslims can say that Muslims
until abrasive most persons are good
Americans mobsters love all mankind
that's why we're sharing this message
because we want the best for you and we
want the best for all mankind please
subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show we made the Filipino
connection to my Manny Pacquiao why keep
Tom any power I keep thinking Filipino
Manny Pacquiao he's a big star over
there he is yeah he's got hurt he's that
you mentioned something he's got a lot
of Muslim friends yeah he has some
people in his corner yeah they're Muslim
but yeah he's mainly known to be
Catholic I believe or I think probably
born again yeah yeah inshallah the
creator of heaven guides him to the way
that Jesus was upon I mean and all the
prophets because they were ones who
connected their heart back to their
maker to their creator direct dial-up we
talk about peace and that's how you get
it by living this way of life many
people they're on Prozac antidepressants
every suicide epidemic every 40 seconds
somebody's taking their life so they
want some of this peace but money can't
buy a six-pack of peace hmm
so what advice do you give people who
are struggling now to get off all this
these drugs people who are struggling
well I don't know man
as someone who as someone who came from
that lifestyle from that night now you
got that piece yeah and now someone
turned in late at night you know maybe
they came back from the club they tuned
in and they're like I want some of this
just in the deepest darkest hour of the
night just ask your Creator
just ask your Creator for the best I
mean that's all I can say is just just
pray to God when I meet people who ask
me for money
you know I tell them I give them give
the money my name is Mohammed you know
pray to God for yourself pray to God for
me
because no one can give you happiness
and no one can like wealth is here man
wealth is here and wealth is that
connection and once you have wealth of
mine wealth of body wealth of soul it
doesn't matter what kind of material
you're surrounded with if you have that
wealth you're good then good subhanAllah
this is so important because why do you
think a lot of people even when you
bring up religion a lot of times it's
not the cool thing a lot of negative
things ah
religion is the source of our war and
evil and you know a lot of esoteric
mystical thing just doesn't make sense
but I mean how do you get even to into
the conversation now today it when I it
because for me personally especially
like people know me a lot for business
and commerce and for my commercial
endeavors it just it has to come out
because that's just what I do
for other people may be different but
for me you know it just it's when I
couldn't it's affected my whole
trajectory in life
every aspect of my life has been
affected by it so when I do speak to
someone on the airplane or someone at
the airport or when I'm traveling or
when I'm here at a restaurant you know
from what I eat to why I'm doing this to
why I'm doing that it just has to come
out in the way that for me you know
someone who wasn't Muslim I know what
goes on in the minds of individuals are
not Muslim so I know what their concerns
are and for a lot of human beings not
even Muslims nuns it's just for a lot of
human beings that's how do I keep the
lights on how do I keep my kids from not
falling to the streets from going into
drugs and falling into this mayhem where
they may lose them and that's where
their concern is so for me wanting
goodness for the human being whether
Muslim non-muslim atheist devil
worshiper
that goodness that has been I don't know
been placed in my heart I want that and
I speak to that person's concerns that
person's needs and you know Eddie it end
up ends up becoming like why are you
like this
or how did you become like this and I go
I don't know man like I you know then by
that time my name has been stated
Mohammed like I do all these things are
you know connected to my faith so
they've already built the association
and they may walk away back and I was a
good man Mohammed is a really nice guy
you know so when I meet people you know
someone asked me if I was it my name is
Mohammed man please pray for me and I'll
pray for you and please pray for
yourself you know and I don't know any
like I I want some of that now they want
they see the the peace the light
resonating and they they want some then
hopefully that God Almighty if there's a
seer that's that's one of the best
advice you know we should seek out with
the purpose of life is why we're here
you know and the best one to ask is the
one who created life the one who created
us and you tell us how do you feel
because we know when we're out there in
the real world dunya affects us see
things affect the heart yeah and you
went out how do you compare being out
there where you was like 24/7 like ebody
you were just and that's how our life's
supposed to be with that right intention
but you won't went out there you were
studying in the desert in different
parts of the world how you just kept how
it's hard to compare that time where you
were just like spiritually now how do
you balance that how was the feeling
then and now it's not about where you're
from it's about where you're at where
you're right and I can bring that back
if I want to because it's it's all here
in the mind and in the heart so living
out there in the desert
living in West Africa studying in the
Middle East or some of the bests and
transformative days of my life period of
my life but I'm a person through the
grace of God and by the permission of
God that if I want to go through that
transformation and change again I can do
that whether it's in Chicago whether
it's in Mexico City whether it's in
London or that's in Mecca because God is
always with me
and if I want it and I'm sincere and
Allah knows me better than I know myself
I'll have it and if I don't have it
probably best I don't happen that's a
great example because many people think
ok to be religious you have to be
somewhere in the desert matter he just
locked up in a mosque all day no you're
a great living example that you're able
to hold the balance you don't get to
sucked up into this material world while
being also in it yeah while striving for
the pleasure of it we're none of the
religion of the middle of the middle
path that's what we're known as people
who you know are delicately delicately
balancing you know fear and hope and
that's what it's always been in every
human being seeks that balance you know
I was coming over here someone was
talking to me about work-life balance
and people wanting that way and you know
you can have it anywhere and it's all
here it's all here and having them
connect and the divine connection to
that just makes it that much better now
there are so many similarities between
Christianity and Islam we have the
Blessed Mother of Jesus the whole
chapters named after her in the Quran
Jesus we love him as a mighty master we
leave he was sent by God but not God and
many people they resonate you know it
connects with them
and people in just in their nature
believe in a Supreme Being the Creator
what what do you say before we leave to
someone now with this whole you know new
atheism you talked to someone said man
get out of here with this religion and
God stuff yeah are you happy
it you know Henry David Thoreau said
that people live in a quiet desperation
and people don't like to be preached to
a lot of us are suffering a lot of us
are feeling our own unique hurting
feelings and we're going through our own
pains and anguishes that are only unique
to us and people may not understand so
for me someone who comes from the way of
muhammad's although I do send them how
can I help how can I be of service to
you how can I make your life better what
can I do
our prophet on that day will say
almighty almighty almighty like my
community my people my people it's not
about himself this life is about being
of service to the people and being of
service to your neighbor being of
service to your parents and just being
of service to humanity and when you do
that God knows your intent God knows
your heart and God will give you what
you deserve
mashallah time is running out we got to
go for the Filipino connection that we
made out there they're tuning in a lot
of people blindly following the cultures
they're upon you know stuck to tradition
you know but they like it resonates you
know what you're saying what advice
would you have for someone out there
from the background from the Filipino
background like it was the way of our
people in history when you look at it
and there was a period of time where
they they had a choice and according to
historians like they chose Islam I mean
and that's a fact
like it's not anything that I'm making
up they they chose a small amazing thank
you so much for being with us here
indeed so we started with peace we end
with peace and that was our special
guest Filipino makiel connection here we
have this way of life growing all over
the world it's amazing and people it
resonates that that what's inside of us
to worship the Creator not the creation
and many of our Christian brethren out
there they also when they see this deep
love that we have for Jesus who was a
mighty messenger Islam and his Blessed
Mother that just resonates and also we
touched upon when people accept this way
of life to see that we live a moderate
way of life balance between not to
getting sucked up into the materialism
in the material world and also not going
off on a deep end on the other side it's
the middle way so many of people who
have accepted this way we also learn
from this story that coming off now many
people have been just brainwashed with
the media take it easy show them through
your good example what a Muslim is being
the best in society developing yourself
to be better each and every day and
that's the blueprint that you have that
will help you to achieve that peace that
money can't buy
subscribe if you haven't already we also
got a number 1 800 662 Islam it doesn't
have to stop there let's start a healthy
dialogue and tune in every week to the
Deen show until next time peace be with
you Sami